Welcome back!
In the previous lessons,
you deploy your own Hadoop clusters.
A long running cluster is great when you
have many jobs and it's in constant use.
However, for many cases, you won't
need a full cluster all the time.
It will just be sitting there idle.
Amazon EC2 instances are charged hourly,
so
if your cluster is idle,
you're wasting money.
A better option is to deploy a cluster
only when you have jobs to run.
When the the tasks are done,
you can shut down the cluster until
the next time you have a job.
Maintaining the cluster also takes
time away from other projects.
For a small organization there might not
be enough people to spend time worrying
about a cluster.
To solve these problems,
you can use an on-demand Hadoop cluster.
Let's look at some options.